lo que tenemos aquí es una lista de los
eventos que podrían ocurrir en un
periodo dado y lo que yo quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver si son o no son y como
contabilizados en el producto interno
bruto especialmente he visto desde una
manera de gastos y bueno de hecho
inténtalo
tú puedes ponerle pausa al vídeo y ver
donde cada uno de estos eventos sucede
en el período para el cual intentamos
calcular el pib y hasta la siguiente
pregunta cómo se contabilizan de acuerdo
a las categorías que yo puse aquí de
acuerdo a los gastos en el pib y bueno
yo voy a suponer que ya lo hiciste que
le pusiste pausa y lo intentaste así que
hagamos dos juntos cada cada mes una
empresa es una empresa sin fines de
lucro nadie realmente es dueño de canadá
min
entonces dice khan academy da emplea un
ingeniero de software y le paga 100 mil
dólares
guau yo quiero trabajar en k'ara k'ara
me espera porque bueno esto es una
empresa haciendo un gasto entonces el
cual también es una inversión porque
esos 100 mil serán usados para generar
códigos que tendrán beneficios futuros
entonces ésta va a caer en la categoría
de inversión lo voy a poner amarillo en
inversión así que tenemos en la inversa
obtendrá más 100 mil dólares y en
general los gastos de empresas van a
caer en lo que es inversión ahora veamos
el siguiente accenture que es otra
empresa gana 10 millones de dólares y en
lugar de poner aquí ganar voy a poner
aquí obtiene obtiene 10 millones de
dólares por los ingresos voy a cambiar
en ingresos acá pongo en ingresos y
después acá pongo obtiene por construir
un nuevo sistema te y para california y
lo importante de pensar aquí es que tú
digas ok ok espera accenture es una
compañía y hablamos del gobierno de
california entonces cómo se contabiliza
eso estamos viendo el lado de los gastos
en el pib entonces aquí tenemos que
california california está gastando 10
millones de dólares en ese periodo para
un nuevo sistema t
por lo tanto aquí tenemos que la
categoría de gobierno será incrementada
por 10 millones de dólares por ese gasto
que se hizo entonces tenemos eso ahora
siguiente mi madre vende su casa en
florida a una mujer italiana por 200.000
dólares
una vez más que vemos aquí una casa está
siendo vendida por alguien en el país a
alguien que es ciudadano extranjero
entonces que hacemos lo importante aquí
están es esta nación a la casa es una
nueva es una casa ya existente entonces
nada nuevo fue producido aquí así que
aquí no hay nada de contribución al pib
no importa si es una ciudadana
extranjera o oa quien se deben de la
casa ya existe antes solamente cambió el
dueño entonces nada fue producido aquí
nada ocurre con el producto interno
bruto ahora tú asumimos que tú compras
una máquina japonesa para cortar pasto
por 200 dólares entonces tienes tu nueva
máquina así que está interesante porque
si lo piensas teóricamente nada fue
producido en eeuu entonces nada nada
debe ser agregado al producto interno
bruto en una base neta entonces pero
pero este caso se agregará al consumo y
se restará a exportaciones netas
entonces dos cosas pasan aquí tú eres un
consumidor entonces tú consumes 200
dólares se agregan al siguiente
es ante aquí lo que va a pasar se lo
quitaremos a exportaciones netas todo lo
demás todo todo se quedará neutral aquí
no hubo compras foráneas pero lo que sí
hubo fue que se compró un producto
extranjero entonces se van a restar 200
dólares en exportaciones netas
exportaciones netas bajarán por 200
dólares esto fue un importe de 200
dólares luego totalmente se cancelan los
200 dólares en consumo así que tenemos
que esto tendrá ser efecto en el
producto interno bruto porque estos dos
de aquí se van a cancelar y como puedes
ver aquí está interesante todo esto a
ver vamos vamos con el siguiente el
siguiente dice que yo compra una casa
nueva por 500 mil dólares y gastos
gastos en bienes raíces por lo general
se consideran consumo
- cuando tú compras una casa nueva así
que aún yo sin ser una empresa y como
estoy comprando una casa nueva
esto entra en lo que es inversión en
inversión así que inversión subirá por
500 mil dólares y finalmente que tenemos
aquí americanairlines american airlines
compra un nuevo avión hecho en europa
entonces qué va a pasar aquí otra vez
neto nada nada fue producido en eeuu así
que en una base neta esto no contribuye
al pib veremos en una base neta esto
será neutral será neutral será como la
situación de arriba hay una compañía
americana que hizo una compra no hay una
cantidad aquí pero supongamos que el
avión vale no sé qué te gusta a 100
millones vamos a decir que vale 100
millones no sé cuánto va algún avión
entonces su inversión subirá a 100
millones inversión subirá más 100
millones entonces que tenemos aquí aquí
tenemos una fábrica americana haciendo
una compra la cual dará dará frutos dará
ganancia en todo porque dará transporte
a personas pero quitaremos porque
tenemos un importe neto por este lado
habrá 100 millones porque fue un importe
pero por este lado cabrá menos menos 100
millones pensado desde el punto de vista
de exportación 100
menos menos 100 millones no hay una
exportación positiva correspondiente así
tendremos que exportaciones netas menos
100 millones y exportaciones
exportaciones netas menos 100 millones
fue un importe de 100 millones hace
sentido será una exportación de 100
millones entonces 100 menos 100 millones
se van a cancelar 100 millones menos y
millones se van a cancelar por lo tanto
aquí no hay un pib lo cual hace sentido
porque este avión no se construyó en
eeuu se construyó fuera en europa